some people the two two suspicious
deaths both arson attacks I understand
one a man called Bullock Forsythe who
had information in relation to child
abuse and significant information the
second one early a couple of years
earlier a caretaker where what was said
at the time was that he had tapes
relating to sex parties that were taking
place that were connected in with this
and that was handed to the police at the
time and got nowhere the bullet Forsythe
one went to the police at the time and
got nowhere what I want to see is both
those suspicious death reinvestigated
because what links them together is both
were people who in essence were blowing
the whistle on child abuse for whatever
motive and two very suspicious deaths so
who tell us more about these two
suspicious deaths how are they treated
at the time do you know and why do they
need to be looked at again now why were
there not looked at sufficiently well
previously well good question and I
don't know why they weren't looked at
sufficient the time the bullet Forsythe
case has been well documented he worked
in the field of Social Care with
children's homes and the evidence about
what he said to have uncovered is a very
precise and relates to what come much
more to light in the last 12 months and
in the last three or four months in
particular his cases is crystal clear
it's clear that his death is highly
suspicious that he had crucial
information about child abuse that the
former death again it was said in his
more investigations to find more details
it was said at the time there was a
caretaker in Lambeth where there was a
very
vicious death from following a fire and
again it was said he was providing
information and tapes relating to sex
abuse and sex parties and information
related to them has been given to
operation Trinity and I'm hoping more
people if they know things will come
forward and because it's an important
part of the inquiry so you're saying
that these two men from what you can
gather they were it would appear
allegedly murdered because of
information that they had about sex
parties in involving young children I'm
saying that they died in suspicious
circumstances and that's what should be
investigated and yes in both cases what
links them is the information was that
they had information and indeed evidence
of child abuse and therefore it becomes
all the more important that those cases
are fully reopened and my fear is not
that an unwillingness in the police to
do it because I've met the police
including on this issue several times
it's whether there's enough resource
available to the police to be able to
carry out investigations and sit two
deaths that took place quite some years
ago which obviously technically is quite
difficult and you think that their
deaths were related to a beautiful ring
that was in some way related to
Westminster undoubtedly linked from what
I have seen and the information I've
been given undoubtedly linked to child
abuse and potentially linked into the
wider scandal and that's why it needs to
be investigated them in there are there
are figures in authority who are linked
in in both cases and therefore all the
more important that they're fully
investigated and that means putting
significant Rizzo
course in we don't pay for the police to
do the job and have enough police doing
it we will not get to the truth and
that's what I'm calling for enough
police officers with enough specialism
in there so that every stone is turned
over to see what lies beneath it that's
certainly a lot there with these two
cases now this file that you've handed
over to the police contains the names of
13 former ministers 22 names in all
amongst them 14 conservatives some of
them are still MPs you say some of them
are still in the House of Lords what do
you hope for having handed over this
file now what sort of information is in
that file well the police asked me I i
I'd compile the list of names I've been
assisting various police forces with
specific pieces of information and
evidence that have come to me but I I
drew together a comprehensive list
talking to other campaigners on the
issue an operation Trinity were very
keen for me to go through that list to
have done with them outlining why these
people could be of interest and you know
these are these are allegations they
they're not proven and you know whether
all of them are guilty of anything I
don't know but having seen the evidence
there with some of the cases without
question without question you know there
should be major investigations and huge
resource put into them because some of
the evidence is quite dramatically is
very very compelling indeed how have you
managed to gain access to this
information and are you suggesting that
police didn't have that access until
you've provided them with the file what
concerns me I mean a lot of these people
who are discussed with the police in
that list are under active police
investigation am pleased and pleased to
see that by different police forces but
what I'm seeing is that there's a lot of
information in and around Westminster
that hadn't come for
there's more still to come forward that
people have had I've spoken to people in
my inquiries who had important pieces of
information and evidence that they
didn't realize was evidence that haven't
been given to the police and there are
people with more information I'm quite
certain of it and as well this former
police officers especially Special
Branch officers some of whom have
contacted me who do have significant
information and if the Official Secrets
Act restrictions are lifted on them will
be willing and far more willing to come
forward and divulge that information I
think some of that would be hugely
significant in moving forward and in
hitting potentially prosecuting some of
these cases is that what you're asking
for the Home Secretary to do it's the
most vital thing that tree zamane needs
to do there are two site one email that
came to me just last week from sooner
was in Special Branch which was well
look we and others have a lot to say but
were restricted by the Official Secrets
Act I've heard that several times now
with people with vital information that
the Official Secrets Act is holding them
back they've signed it it would be a
criminal offense to say anything the
restrictions of the Official Secrets Act
in relation to historic child abuse need
to be lifted by Theresa May or by
Parliament if that's what's required in
order that those people actually in
reality feel compelled to come forward
and share the information that they have
don't forget Special Branch was keeping
an eye particularly on senior MPs and
there's a lot of information there that
is not available to those police
officers investigating at the moment you
appear certainly mr. Mann from what
you're telling us here on Sky News this
afternoon to have a smoking gun
obviously you're not going to do it on
our program today but at any stage in
the future are you considering using
parliamentary privilege to name those on
this list now I think it'd been
inappropriate for me or indeed any other
MP
II to do that and the reason is that the
critic the two critical things to me the
first is that the voice of the victims
is heard I've heard some harrowing
harrowing tales of what people went
through as children well the victims of
a right to be believed and I think
that's fundamental but secondly some of
the alleged perpetrators are still alive
the last thing that's needed is me or
any other MP getting up and using
parliamentary privilege and potentially
jeopardizing a criminal trial that could
lead to them being jailed if these
perpetrators and the evidence is true
they should go to court stand trial let
a jury decide whether the guilty or not
and if they are let's have them in